EVERYONE TO OUR MONDAY DECEMBER
NINTH OF LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE HEARING AND WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
AS A SUB COMMITTEE GIVEN THE
TIME CONSTRAINTS THAT WE HAVE
ALSO I'M GONNA IF YOU'RE A
LITTLE BIT AWAY FROM MY NORMAL
PRACTICE ALLOWING SIX MINUTES
IT'S FOR EACH SIDE WITH TWO
FOUR MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE IF
YOU DO HAVE SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND OF
COURSE THE SENATE'S ALSO. IS
SESSION AS WELL. OKAY THE
SERVER IRWIN I HAVE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IT YOURS IS A
RELATIVELY BRIEF. YES I GUESS
IT DEPENDS ON US TO. I GUESS IT
DEPENDS ON US TOO. AND THIS IS
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY SIX AS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE CLARIFIES. AMBIGUITY IN
THE CURRENT LAW RELATING TO
PART TIME ADJUNCT FACULTY AT
NONPROFIT INDEPENDENT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES RECENTLY
SEVERAL SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
FORCED TO TREAT ADJUNCT FACULTY
MEMBERS AS TIME COURT EMPLOYEES
WHO HAVE TO TRACK HOURS WORKED.
AND MEAL AND REST BREAKS THIS
BILL WILL ENABLE ADJUNCT
FACULTY AT THE SCHOOLS TO
CONTINUE TO BE TREATED AS AG
EXEMPT PROFESSIONALS. IT SETS A
MINIMUM CAUGHT COMPENSATION FOR
BASED ON A FORMULA FOR TOTAL
HOURS. OF SERVICE NOT JUST
CLASS FROM TIME TO ACCOUNT FOR
TIME PREPARING. LESSONS GRADING
ASSIGNMENTS AND RESPONDING TO
STUDENTS AND REALLY APPRECIATE
BOTH A ICC YOU AND ASK YOU HOW
YOU. OF LOT OF TOUGH
NEGOTIATIONS TO GET THIS BILL
TO THE POINT IT IS NOW. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
ALEX GRAVES WITH THE
ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES WE REPRESENT
EIGHTY FIVE NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS IN THE STATE. AS
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL JUST
VERY APPRECIATIVE AND THANKFUL
FOR ALL THE WORK ON THIS AND
THIS RELEASE IS DESIGNED TO
CREATE A NARROW. PATHWAY TO
COMPLIANCE FOR INSTITUTIONS TO
CONTINUE TO TREAT ADJUNCTS AS
THE PROFESSIONALS THAT THEY ARE
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. EMILY ROSE
MURDER WITH SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION AGAIN I
WANT TO ECHO THE SAME.
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORED THE
SPONSOR FOR THEIR HARD WORK IN
ESTABLISHING A MUCH NEEDED
FLOOR IN RECOGNIZING THESE AYE
JONES. OF FOR THE STRUCTURE
PROFESSIONALISM THAT THEY DO
EVERY DAY AT THE. DIVERSITY
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT FOR THE
TEAMSTERS I APOLOGIZE WE ARE OF
A LETTER ON FILE BUT WE'RE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION. THEY WILL WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION WHEN WE HAVE
A QUORUM OF THE SIMILAR WHICH
LIKE CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY SENATOR DO THE RUSSELL SB
TWO EIGHTY SIX. YOU MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I WANT TO BEGIN
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE VERY
MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK AND
YOUR SUPPORT ON A ON THE
ANALYSIS I'M PROUD TO AUTHOR US
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY SIX TO
ADDRESS A LABOR CODE ISSUE.
THAT HAS ARISEN REGARDING
INTERPRETATION OF SIX INTO A
ONE THE DISCHARGE STATUTE AND
IN WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES IT SHOULD
APPLY IN THE CONTEXT OF WORKERS
AT BASEBALL PARKS IN THE STATE.
I'VE WORKED VERY CLOSELY AND
I'M ALSO VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
S. CI YOU THE TEAMSTERS UNITED
HERE SELA CA O. C. AND OTHERS.
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES. AND THAT.
LEADS TO A CLARIFICATION OF THE
LABOR CODE TO MAINTAIN THE
CURRENT PRACTICE OF WHAT WE
WANT IS THAT WORKERS WHAT THE
PRACTICE HAS BEEN IS THAT
WORKERS OF ALWAYS BEEN PAID ON
THE REGULAR PAY PERIOD AND THAT
THAT WILL CONTINUE. WITHOUT THE
NEED TO DISBURSE PAYMENTS AT
THE END OF GAMES CONCERTS OR
OTHER EVENTS AT THE BALL PARKS
THIS IS WELL ESTABLISHED WELL
ACCEPTED PRACTICE PARTIALLY
BECAUSE OF THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS AT ALL
THE BEST BASEBALL PARKS. AND
IT'S JUST THE PRACTICE THAT HAS.
BEEN ACCEPTED AND US SUPPORTED
BY THE EMPLOYEES OF WITH ME OUR
SAN FERNANDO IS EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT AND GENERAL COUNSEL
OF THE LOS ANGELES DODGERS. AND
AMY TOOLBAR VICE PRESIDENT AND
DEPUTY GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS. I AM SO
GLAD WE WON AT LEAST ONE OF THE
GAMES. WHO WOULD EVER THINK I
WOULD BE SITTING THERE WITH THE
TWO TEAMS BUT I'M THIS GOES TO
SHOW YOU THAT THERE IS HOPE. TO
KEEP OUR TO BUILD UNITY IN
SPITE OF OURS OR BASEBALL
AFFILIATIONS SO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WHICH MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU AND BEFORE WE GO ON TO THE
NEW WITNESS TESTIMONY IF WE CAN
HAVE CORPSMAN STYLISH PLEASE.
KALRA LARA. YEP GONZALEZ JONES
SAWYER THERE IS REPORTS. NOW
YEAH. ALL RIGHT SO QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED AS INDICATED
EARLIER. A LITTLE BIT SHORTENED
VERSION OF MY NORMAL PRACTICE
UP TO FOUR MINUTES YOU CAN
SPLIT IT UP ANY WAY YOU CHOOSE.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
MISTER TERRILL THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND THANK YOU TO THE SENATOR
FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND GETTING
THIS THROUGH WE'VE WORKED VERY
HARD WITH A NUMBER OF IFFERENT
GROUPS STATE TO COME UP WITH
THAT A SENSIBLE BILL THAT WILL
PROTECT THE PRACTICE THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AT PAYING OUR
EMPLOYEES ON REGULAR PAYDAYS.
ON OUR LAST REGULAR AT LEAST
SCHEDULE GAME THIS SEASON IS
SUNDAY SEPTEMBER TWENTY NINTH.
NY PLAYING SAM'S TEAM. IT'S
ALWAYS A EXCITING WHEN WE'RE
PAYING PLAYING OUR RIVALS. BUT
IT WOULD BE REALLY IMPOSSIBLE
IF WE WERE REQUIRED TO PAY ALL
OF OUR BALLPARK EMPLOYEES AT
THE END OF THAT GAME. WHEN YOU
COUNT OUR- AYE SUREST TICKET
TAKERS SECURITY GUARDS. AB
CONCESSION WORKERS WE HAVE OVER
THREE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES THAT
WOULD THAT WORK EVENTS AND SO.
TO REQUIRE THE TEAMS. TO STAY
AND SOMEHOW MANAGED TO PAY
EVERYONE AT THE END OF THIS
GAME. IS REALLY IMPOSSIBLE
IMPRACTICAL AND COULD LEAD TO
ERRORS IN PAY WHICH IS WHAT WE
REALLY WANT TO INVITE. INSTEAD
THOSE WORKERS THAT ARE THERE ON
THE TWENTY NINTH WILL BE PAID
FIVE DAYS LATER ON FRIDAY
OCTOBER FOURTH. AB SO WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT WORKS EVER SINCE WE
WERE SEATED ON THIS ISSUE.
WE'VE RENEGOTIATED OUR CBA'S
WITH OUR EMPLOYEE UNIONS IN
THIS IS NOT BEEN RAISED. AS A
CONCERN BY OUR UNION SO. WE ASK
YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF.
PROTECTING A PRE PACKED A
PRACTICE THAT WORKS. AND NOT
REQUIRE. TO DISRUPT THAT
PRACTICE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. SAN
FERNANDO IS A MAY HAVE THE
DODGERS. I'D I I'D LIKE TO ECHO
WHAT AMY JUST SAID I WOULD LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT THIS IS A
PRACTICE IT'S- BEEN IN PLACE
FOR. MANY MANY YEARS CERTAINLY
THROUGHOUT THE TIME THAT I'VE
BEEN GENERAL COUNSEL WHICH IS
THIRTY SIX YEARS. WITH THE
DODGERS. IT REALLY REFLECTS THE-
PRACTICAL OR REALLY THE
IMPOSSIBILITY OF PAIN OUR
EMPLOYEES ARE DAVE GAME
EMPLOYEES AT THE END OF A GAME
OR OR OF AN EVENT OR- ANY
POSSIBILITY SOMETIMES OF
DETERMINING WHEN THE SEASON
WELL AND- I AM CHAU. WE THANK
SENATOR DRAWS IT WAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO AND THE OTHER
AUTHORS OF THE BILL AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIR CRISPY KAYLEE ON BEHALF
OF THE OAKLAND A IS THAT LOS
ANGELES ANGELS AND THE SAN
DIEGO PADRES ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROAD
I THINK I'M A TWEENER JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT FOR THE
TEAMSTERS AND UNITE HERE THAT
WE ARE NEUTRAL. THAT WE THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US
ON A SET OF AMENDMENTS THAT
GODDESS THERE WE BELIEVE THAT
THE BILL PROVIDES STATUTORY
CLARIFICATION FOR THE PRACTICES
THAT AS- WE'VE ALWAYS. ASSUME
THAT THE WAY IT WORKS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. CAN REALLY RESONATE
WITH SK YOU CALIFORNIA I WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE WITH THE TEAMSTERS
AND UNITE HERE AND SAY THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK AND WE
WERE MEAN. ESPECIALLY NEUTRAL
THANK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MERRY GO
YOSHI HARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PLANET LAWYERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
WANT TO THANK SENATOR ALSO FOR.
LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS IN
ADDRESSING THOSE THROUGH
AMENDMENTS AWARE ALSO NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU. JACKIE STERN ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
AND YOUR WONDERFUL STAFF FOR
REACHING A COMPROMISE AND WE
ARE NEUTRON THE BILL AS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. HI. IF YOU LIKE TO
SEE HERE YOU CAN. PLEASE. IT
WAS A DONE DEAL BE ON BEHALF OF
THE- WORKING STADIUMS. WE
THOUGHT WE HEARD TODAY ABOUT MY
NAME IS DENNIS MáS ACTUALLY.
THERE IS LABOR CO TWO ALL ONE
HAS A LENGTHY HISTORY IN
NINETEEN ELEVEN IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED LEGISLATION. TECH PEOPLE
WHEN THEY'RE LAID OFF FROM WORK.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WHEN YOU'RE
LAID OFF FROM WORK IN THE
LEGISLATIVE HISTORY BACK IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN HUNDRED SAYS.
IT'S FOR THE NECESSITIES OF
LIFE PEOPLE WHO WERE LAID OFF
ME THEIR PAY. PROMPTLY. NO
JUST. THE GIANTS AND DODGERS TO
PAY SOMEBODY AT THE END OF THE
GAME. THE END OF THE SEASON HAD
DIFFICULTY DOESN'T CHANGE THE
LAW. BUT WAIT FOR THE PROPOSED
HERE GIVES YOU TO WE GIVE THEM
TO OVER TWO WEEKS IF YOU IF IT
BILL TALK ABOUT LABOR CO TWO OH
FOUR. IT SO HAPPENS MAYBE IF
THE SEASON ENDS ON THE END OF
THE MONTH. TO BE PAID IN FIVE
DAYS. BUT IF THEY'RE PAID ON
THE SECOND OR THIRD IF THE LAST
NAMES THE SECOND OR THIRD.
THEIR PAY TWO WEEKS LATER THESE
PEOPLE NEED THEIR MONEY THAT
WAS THE ENTIRE PURPOSE OF THIS
LAW ORIGINALLY. IN THE NINETEEN
FORTIES THE CANNING CURING. AND
DRYING INDUSTRIES GOT AN
EXCEPTION TO THE LAW. THOSE
INDUSTRIES OF SEVENTY TWO HOURS.
THE GIANTS THE DODGERS IT WAS
MODERN TECHNOLOGY WITH DIRECT
DEPOSIT THE SYNCHRONIZATION OF
TIME RECORDS AND PAY RECORDS
CAN EASILY ME A SEVENTY TWO
HOUR RULE THEY DON'T HAVE TO
CALCULATE IT AT THE END OF THE
LAST GAME IF YOU AMEND THE BILL
TO MAKE IT SO PEOPLE GET PAID
PROMPTLY. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
THE DRILLING INDUSTRY WHEN OIL
WELLS DRY UP THE DRILLING
INDUSTRY CAME THE LEGISLATURE
TO SAID. WE NEED AN EXCEPTION
IS TOO HARD TO GET THE CHECKS
OUT TO THESE PEOPLE. THEY GOT A
TWENTY FOUR HOUR EXCEPTION.
WITH A RULE THAT SAYS IF IT
FALLS ON A WEEKEND YOU CAN YOU
DON'T COUNT THE WEEKEND DAYS. I
THINK BASEBALL CAN DO THAT I
THINK BASEBALL DOESN'T HAVE TO
MAKE THEIR EMPLOYEES WAIT. AND
IT'S HIGHER UP TO TWO OR MORE
WEEKS TO PAY THEIR EMPLOYEES
AND YOU KNOW THIS IS A PRO.
EMPLOYEE LEGISLATURE SOME OF
YOU MARCHED WITH THE FURLOUGHED
WORKERS OF THE STATE WELL THESE
ARE FURLOUGHED WORKERS BUT
THESE ARE FURLOUGHED WORKERS
WHO ARE POSSIBLY IN THE WORKING
POOR. THE HOT DOG VENDORS THE
PIER SELLERS THEY WORK HARDER
THAN SOME OF THESE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR. A YEAR PITCHERS
WALKING UP AND DOWN THOSE
AISLES WITH CARING BEER SELLING
HOT DOGS AND THE USHERS IN THE-
THESE ARE THESE ARE WORKING
PEOPLE OF MANY OF WHOM. MAYBE
YOUR CONSTITUENTS. I KNOW IN
LOS ANGELES YOU'RE A LOT OF
WORKERS AT DODGER STADIUM WHO
WORK THROUGHOUT THE CITY. YOU
COULD DO DIRECT DEPOSIT IN A
WEEK YOU CAN DO DIRECTOR MAYBE
A WEEK IF SEVENTY TWO HOURS IS
THAT TOUGH. FOR THE GIANTS THE
DODGERS MAKE IT A WEEK. BUT I
STILL THINK THEY COULD DO IN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF THEY HAVE
TO THEY CAN EVEN DO IT
IMMEDIATELY AND COMPLY WITH THE
LAW. THE FACT THAT THERE'S BEEN
A TRADITION FOR ALL THESE YEARS
NOT TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW.
DOESN'T MAKE IT RIGHT. DOESN'T
MAKE IT CORRECT. I UNDERSTAND
THAT LABOR AND MANAGEMENT OF
GOT ALONG FOR YEARS ALLOWING
THIS TO HAPPEN. THEY MAY HAVE
HAD MORE IMPORTANT THINGS TO DO
BUT THE REALITY IS THESE
WORKERS NEED THEIR MONEY. THEY
NEED THEIR MONEY WOULD BE NICE
TO GET A TOMB SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER. YOU HAVE TO PAY
THEIR BILLS THEIR CREDIT CARD
DEBT INTERESTS IS GOING UP YET
TO FEED THEIR FAMILIES NEED TO
FOR TRANSPORTATION. WHY MAKE IT
TWO WEEKS. AND THAT'S WITH THE
BILL ALLOWS IN THIS LABOR CO
TWO OH FORCE RIGHT I URGE YOU.
THINK VERY HARD ABOUT THIS. AND
THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE INVOLVED. AND
MAYBE WHAT YOU NEED TO DO IS
TABLE ISN'T STUDY THE- AND IT'S
ODD TO ME THIS IS THE ONLY
INDUSTRY. YOU HAVE TO CUT YOU
OUT DRIVE TO COME BACK NEXT
YEAR FOR BASKETBALL AND SOCCER.
AND IN AGRICULTURE IN
AGRICULTURE PEOPLE LOOK THE
PROPS YOUR PET. THEY'RE ABLE TO
PAY PEOPLE WITHIN A WEEK THAT
VIOLATES THE LAW SUPPOSED TO
PAY THEM IMMEDIATELY. BUT IT
REALLY IS A PROBLEM THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
FEEDBACK. OF ANYONE ELSE
SUPPOSED. OKAY RETURNED BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THAT'S THE RUMOR
GONZALEZ. I THINK I'M USING
YEARS I DO HAVE A QUESTION AND
YOU MAY NOT KNOW THE ANSWER
NINE IN. I LITERALLY DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER ARE CSEA EMPLOYEES.
AT THE END OF THE SCHOOL YEAR
ARE THEY IS THERE TIME GIVEN.
DOES ANYONE NOW. I WAS JUST
CURIOUS BECAUSE IT IS SOMEWHAT.
SIMILAR REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES
WHO KIND OF HAVE A DIFFERENT
EXPECTATION AND AN END THERE
BECAUSE THEY TECHNICALLY LOSE
THEIR JOB EVERY YEAR BASICALLY
ANYWAY JUST A CURIOSITY OF HOW
HOW THEY'RE DEALT WITH I
THOUGHT I THOUGHT THAT THEY
WERE ON A REGULAR PAY SCHEDULE
I COULD BE WRONG ABOUT THAT
THOUGH SO I DON'T MAKE THAT
STATEMENT. WITH THAT I A I AND
I BY ALL MEANS UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS RAISED BUT I THINK
GIVEN THAT THESE WORKERS ARE
REPRESENTED IN THE UNIONS
APPEAR TO HAVE COME TO SOME
SORT OF AGREEMENT I'M WILLING
TO MOVE THIS BILL. WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FOR VICE CHAIR SECOND BY
A SUMMER CARILLO. BUT THANK YOU
FOR THE- COMMENTS ANY OTHER. I
WANT TO THANK THE YES. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
AM PROUD TO BE A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL. PROUD AT
DODGER STADIUM IS. IN THE HOME
OF SIMPLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE I
COME FRESH OFF THE FIELD AFTER
A CURB STRIKE YESTERDAY THAT I
GOT TO IT. IT SHOULD ITCH IN
THE FIRST PITCH OF THE GAME AND
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACTUALLY ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
WORKERS WHO MAKE THE EXPERIENCE
OF EVERY BASEBALL GAME SUCH A
WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE FOR
FAMILIES. IN OUR DISTRICT AND
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND I'M GLAD TO HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO PLAY A ROLE IN FACILITATING
SOME OF THE VERY EARLY ON
CONVERSATIONS TO MAKE SURE
THAT. ALL THE FOLKS AT THE
TABLE CAME TO AN AGREEMENT THAT
WORK FOR EVERYONE. SO WITH THAT
I'M I'M REALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BILL AND THAT THANK YOU
FOR ALL THE COMMITMENT THAT'S
BEEN DONE THE SENATOR AND I.
SHARE THE DODGERS AND LOVED THE
DODGERS SEND THE NO OFFENSE TO
THE GIANTS. WE LOVE WE LOVE THE
RIVALRY ACTUALLY AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT MAKES
GOING TO A GAME SO YOU SO
WONDERFUL UNIQUE BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY. THE PEOPLE THAT
WORK THERE THE PEOPLE AT THE
STADIUMS THAT MAKE OUR
EXPERIENCE ASK BANDS SO
INCREDIBLY UNIQUE SO THANK YOU.
I AGREE AND THANK YOU. IS
INSTEAD OF ON A THANK YOU. AND
REALLY EVERYONE INVOLVED IN
THIS IS FIRST BROUGHT TO MY
DESK I WASN'T SURE IF WE'D BE
ABLE TO GET TO THIS PLACE SO
QUICKLY. A LOT OF WORK WAS PUT
INTO INCLUDING OF MY LOOK UP
COMMITTEE STAFF. AND HAD I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO NOT ONLY
SPEAK TO THE TO. THE OPPOSITION
AND THEIR CONCERNS AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE LABOR UNIONS. THE
END OF THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
MAY HAVE HAD. BUT ALSO SOME OF
THE MANAGER FROM THE TEAM TO
CLEAN THE GIANTS MAYS AND- UP
TO GET MORE FEEDBACK MORE GET
LITTLE MORE THE WEEDS AS TOP
THE OPERATIONS AND- THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE. ARE SO MANY
EIGHT UNIONS THAT ARE INVOLVED
IN THE OPERATION. OF MEDIUMS
MAKES A DIFFERENCE TO ME. UP TO
KNOW THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
A VOICE AND HAVE. THAT
REPRESENTATION. BUT I THINK
THEY'LL BE BELIEVE HE LANDED A
PLACE THAT I THINK. IS FAIR.
ALLOWS FOR A REASONABLE
OPERATIONS. ALLOWS A WORKERS
HAVE A VOICE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CONTINUE. TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE THAT WOULD BE CERTAINLY
ALL ENJOY. AND SO I'M HAPPY TO.
A RECOMMENDED I ON THIS AND THE
WRECK OF THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
TO THE FLOOR. CENTER WHICH
LIKE. CLOSING COMMENTS I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOUR
PRIMARY CONCERN IS THAT OF THE
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN. AND
THAT'S A DROVE. DRIVES YOU IN
THIS COMMITTEE AND THAT'S WHAT
DROVE ME. IT YOU KNOW WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO THE MANAGEMENT.
AND THEIR ROLE. WHAT WAS
IMPORTANT TO THOSE WORKERS. IS
TO KEEP THIS PRACTICE STATE
GIVES THEM THE STABILITY. AND I
AM WATCHED OUT FOR THOSE.
LOOKING FOR LEASE. AND I DO
TALK TO THEM AND- TO
UNDERSTAND. WHAT IT IS AT THE
END. WHAT IS THAT THEY HAVE.
FOR OVER YEARS WHAT IS. THE
STANDARD. EIGHT STANDARD THEY.
HAVE AND NO. THOSE INDIANS. SO
THANK YOU AND BINGO HAD NOT AT
THE LOCAL MADAM SECTOR. MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR KALRA KALRA AYE FLORA BY
FLORA I CARILLO. IDEA THE UP HI
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER BY JONES SAWYER I
THREE OF US. THE OTHER THAT
BILL WILL BE HEADING OVER TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU EVERYBODY.
YES WE CAN UP IF WE CAN HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON ITEM ONE
A. B. FORTY FIFTY SIX THAT'S A
SUMMER WAS ABOUT. IT'S OUR
SECOND A SECOND FROM A VICE
CHAIR. OF SO WE CAN DO A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON THEIR WINDOW ITEM
ONE. MOTION IS RED RECOMMENDED
THAT SENATE AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA FLORA I CREEL. REAL
IDEA YEP I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES SAWYER HI JONES SAWYER
UNDER THREE BEST. THANKS FOR
THAT PASSES THAT'LL BE HEADING
FOR CONCURRENCE ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR AND NOW WE HAVE UP ALSO
TO BE ADOPTED THE FOR ACR ONE
TWENTY FIVE FROM SUMMER JONES
SAWYER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR CLARIFICATION.
THESE ARE NOT GIANT COLORS WELL.
NEED TO PROMOTE THE DEVELOPMENT
AND USE OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES
THAT WERE REDUCE BIAS AND HELP
EMPLOYERS FIND THE BEST SUITED
CANDIDATES BASED ON OBJECTIVE
FACTORS. CALIFORNIA HAS ONE IN
MOST DIVERSE POPULATIONS BUT
THE SAME CANNOT BE SAID OF THE
CORPORATE WORK FORCE FOR
EXAMPLE. SILICON VALLEY TECH
SECTOR MISTER CHAIR. JUST THREE
POINT 3% OF EMPLOYEES ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN SIX POINT SIX
ARE LATINO AND ONLY THIRTY SIX
POINT SEVEN ARE WOMEN. FURTHER
A TWENTY SEVENTEEN STUDY FOUND
THAT SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
WHITE APPLICANTS RECEIVED
THIRTY SIX MORE CALL BACK FROM
THEM THEM BLACK APPLICANTS AND
24% MORE CALL BACK THEN
HISPANIC. APPLICANTS WITH
IDENTICAL RESUMES ACR WENT TO
FIVE URGES POLICY MAKERS AND
FEDERAL AND STATE GOVERNMENT TO
EXPLORE WAYS TO PROMOTE THE
DEVELOPMENT AND USE OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT REDUCE BIAS
AND DISCRIMINATION HIRING. HELP
EMPLOYERS FIND THE BEST SUITED
CANDIDATES BASED ON OBJECTIVE
FACTORS AND HELP ENSURE THAT
ALL PERSONS WHO SEEK OBTAIN AN
HOLD EMPLOYMENT IN THIS STATE
ARE ABLE TO DO SO FREE OF
DISCRIMINATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YA VOTE. THANK YOU
STRESS HI GREG HE'S HERE ON
BEHALF OF MY METRICS. AND IT
JUST WANNA POINT OUT A FEW
THINGS FIRST OF ALL I WE ALL
KNOW HIRING BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION IS A HISTORIC
PROBLEM AND IT HASN'T ABATED.
THE CHALLENGE THAT MANY OF US
ARE NOT AWARE OF ITS IN THE
LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS THE
INTERNET HAS TRANSFORMED HIRING
WHERE AS AN HR MANAGER MAY HAVE
PREVIOUSLY RECEIVED. A DOZEN
RESUMES ON THEIR DESK FOR
PARTICULAR JOB THEY RECEIVE
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS AND
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH A- RESUME
IS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE WORST
PREDICTORS OF A PERSON'S FUTURE
JOB PERFORMANCE. IT YET IT IS
ONE OF THE MOST OFTEN USED AND
WE ALL KNOW WE CAN AVOID IT YOU
LOOK AT A RESUME YOU LOOK AT
NAMES YOU LOOK AT WHERE PEOPLE
WENT TO COLLEGE IS THAT SAID DR
AND YOU'RE MAKING JUDGMENTS
ALREADY. SO AS TECHNOLOGY HAS
EXACERBATED THAT PROBLEM THIS
RESOLUTION POINTS OUT THAT
TECHNOLOGY ALSO COULD HELP
SOLVE SOME OF THE PROBLEM WITH
THAT INHERENT BIAS BY OFFERING
NEW INNOVATIVE SELECTION
CRITERIA THAT LEVERAGES
SCIENCE. TO TRY TO CREATE A
BLIND HIRING PROCESS THE
PROBLEM WITH HIRING. IS AT THE
FRONT END OF THE FINAL I AM
SURE EVERYBODY THIS. MANY IS A
WHERE THE LAW PERMITS
DISCRIMINATION IN HIRING IF YOU
COULD HAVE A JOB JUSTIFICATION
IT REQUIRES YOU TO USE. IN THE
LIGHTS AS THE LEAST
DISCRIMINATORY OPTION BUT
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN CASE LOW
OVER TIME IS THAT BURDENS BEEN
PUT ON THE PLAINTIFF. AND SO
THEREFORE WE'VE NOT MADE MUCH
STRIDES IN THE LEAST
DISCRIMINATORY OPTION WHAT'S
HAPPENED IS IT'S CODIFIED IN
CASE LAW WHAT ALL THESE
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES FOR
JOB JUSTIFICATIONS WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS TRYING TO OPEN UP
THE FINAL ON THE FRONT AND WITH
THE NEW INNOVATIVE SELECTION
CRITERIA. WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S HI CONSIDERATION
OF THIS. RESOLUTION WHICH
HOPEFULLY IS THE BEGINNING OF
WORK TOWARDS THAT END THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE'S
SUPPORT. ANY OPPOSITION. BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE SOME OF
HIS OFFICE I'M GONNA VOTE FOR
THIS TODAY IT MAKES ME VERY
NERVOUS BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS BY IS FREE
AND I THINK THAT IT IT COULD
VERY WELL CREATE NEW PROBLEMS
I'M NOT SUPPORT OF EVERY PLACE
SEEN AT HR DIRECTORS AN H. R.
WORKERS WITH TECHNOLOGY. AT AYE
AYE A. ONLY VOTING FOR BECAUSE
I TRUST THE AUTHOR SO
COMPLETELY AND KNOWING ALL
THESE THINGS THAT I THINK ANY
FUTURE LEGISLATION THAT MAY
COME OUT OF THIS HE WILL LOOK
AT CLOSELY AND MAKE SURE WE'RE
NOT. TRADING ONE EVIL FOR
ANOTHER. THAT AS OF MOTHER OF A
CHILD WHOSE NAME IS TIARA ANY
GOOD GONZALEZ HAMMOND'S AND IN
NO WAY CAN. AS SHE WILL OFTEN
REMIND ME. DESPITE HER GREAT
CREDENTIALS SELDOM GETS PASSED
THE FIRST LOOK ACTUALLY IN MANY
AT. EVEN SERVICE SECTOR JOBS
WHICH IS SHOCKING GIVEN HER HER
RESUME BUT I KNOW THAT THAT'S A
REAL THING SO AT I AM GONNA GO
AHEAD AND SUPPORT THIS I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT I AM I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT ANY. FUTURE
LEGISLATION THAT COULD COME OUT
OF THIS. THE OTHER COMMENT. WE
HAVE HELLO THIS IS A MOTION ON
CLIMATE HOPE OF A VICE CHAIR IS
OUR SECOND SECOND SORRY. CREEL
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND I'LL
JUST. TO US ARGUES OFFICES
POINT FIRST OF ALL I THINK OF
THE ELECTED OFFICIALS IN.
SILICON VALLEY I PRICE SPEAK
MORE TO. HIRING DISPARITIES OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR PARTICULARLY
KNOWS AFTER AMERICANS AND OF
WOMEN. MORE VOCALLY PROBABLY
THAN ALMOST ANYONE AND SO THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
ME. BEING IN SILICON VALLEY AND
I THINK ALL OF US CERTAINLY ON
THIS PANEL. ON THE SEARCH
COMMITTEE. BUT I DO SHARES A
HEALTHY DOSE OF CYNICISM AS
WELL AS TO WHETHER TECHNOLOGY
IS THE IS THE SOLUTION TO IT.
BUT I'M CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN
LEARNING MORE AND I THINK THAT
THIS. IF THIS IF THIS IS A WAY
FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD AND
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY I THINK IT
CAN BE A TOOL AGAIN I AGREE
THAT WE DON'T NESTLE ONE OF
DAYS OUT. A CERTAIN SECTOR OF
EMPLOYMENT BUT IF THIS CAN BE A
TOOL. TO HELP DEAL WITH ARE
IMPLICIT BIASES. THAT'S WHAT
I'M INTERESTED IN LEARNING MORE
ABOUT AND SOME BOX NATIVE IN
THIS. AREA I IN TERMS OF THE
CAPACITY OF SOFTWARE BUT I DO
ALSO SHARE SOME OF THE CYNICISM
IN TERMS OF ITS ABILITY TO DO
IT BECAUSE THE INPUTS. ARE.
STILL BEING PUT. QUITE IS
DETERMINED. TO HAVE THOSE SAME
BIASES AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
LEARNING MORE. AND I THINK THAT
THIS IS DEFINITELY A
CONVERSATION WE NEED TO HAVE.
AND I DEFTLY SUPPORT THE END
GOAL OF WHAT THE REAL
RESOLUTION IS SEEKING AND SO
FOR THAT REASON I SUPPORT IT.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
WORK AT. AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS. AND
I NEED ALL OF THIS FEEDBACK
EVERY LAST ONE TO ENSURE THAT.
THIS WHAT OUR ALGORITHMS WE
COME UP WITH WE A AYE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WOULD DOESN'T
TURN INTO A NIGHTMARE. I CAN
TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THIS WAS
ESPECIALLY SUPPOSED JUST BE A
TOOL FOR HUMAN RESOURCE PEOPLE
NOT TO REPLACE THEM THIS IS
SUPPOSED TO HELP THEM. LOOK AT
THEMSELVES AND HELP WITH THEIR
IMPLICIT BIASES SO WEAKENED
WEEDED OUT THIS IS NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE THE BE ALL AND END ALL IS
NOT THE ULTIMATE ANSWER IT IS
JUST A TOOL TO SOMEONE CAN USE
A TOOL BOX. TO GET THE MOST
DIVERSE BOB CAN IT IS THAT THEY
CAN'T IT WILL HELP THE INDUSTRY
OR INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA
ULTIMATELY A I ALSO LOOK AT.
YOU KNOW I YOU KNOW I DO A LOT
OF THINGS WITH. COLONEL JUSTICE
AND I KNOW PEOPLE WHO HAVE A
FROM A RECORD AS SOON AS THEY
SEE THAT THEY GET PHONE ADDRESS
CAN'T AND WE NEVER GET TO STEP
TWO AND THREE SO I HAVE OTHER.
USES THAT WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS DOES NOT. THIS DOES
BECOME SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE AS A
TEASE COLONEL JUSTICE HIRING
ALL OF THAT COULD BE VERY. THIS
TECHNOLOGY COULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT IN FOR THE NECOLE SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE BUT WE
DO KNOW WHAT LET'S LOOK ABOUT
AS A DRINK LAST QUARTER CENTURY
HASN'T WORKING. SO WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO LOOK AT.
LOOK AT MORE WELL THAT WE CAN
DO. SO I THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
EXCERPTED WILL PLEASE. MOTION
IS BE ADOPTED TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR KALRA. KALRA AYE FLORA
FLORA I'D CREEL. CREO HI YEP.
YEP I CAN SALAS GONZALEZ SIDE
JONES SAWYER BY JONES SAWYER I
THREE OF US THREE OF US I.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TWELVE
FIFTY NINE PEOPLE GO HEAD TO
THE FLOOR AND US ARE REVERSED
LIKE OUT ON. THE OTHER TWO
ITEMS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. JUST
SLOWLY ROLL